Now that we've declared an initialized variable,
let's see how we can use it to keep track of the number of people on a bus.
Say our bus starts by picking up five more passengers at the first stop.
This basically means we want to add five to our passengers variable here.
One thing we can do with variables is update it by building on its old value.
This is done by writing the variable name,
and then an equal sign,
and then the variable name again,
and then plus whatever value we want to add to it.
Now, when you look at a statement like this,
it might seem weird at first.
How can passengers be equal to passengers plus five?
Well, remember that this is not a mathematical statement.
It's a computer programming statement,
more like an instruction or command.
We're basically telling the computer to change
the value of passengers to become the old value plus five.
The way computers translate its statements like
this is by starting from the right hand side of the equal sign.
The computer calculates whatever this right hand side is,
which is the old value plus five,
and then sets it into the left hand side of the equal sign.
That's why you should only have
one variable on the left hand side of the equal sign here.
Remember, we're not giving the computer a math puzzle to solve.
We're giving them clear and precise instructions,
that is, update passengers to become all passengers plus five.
Now, I assume the bus continues to go
and is supposed to drop off three passengers in the next stop.
So, we basically want to subtract three from our variable passengers here.
It's exactly the same as adding to it.
We just type in the variable name equals
the variable name again minus whatever value we want to subtract.
So, this would update the variable passengers,
setting it to whatever old value it was minus three.
Brilliant. So now our passengers is updated and our bus keeps moving on.
Say at this stop one passenger leaves the bus and five more hop on.
What would you write here to update our passengers variable to subtract one and add five?